all right welcome to your unboxing and
first look at the new green colorways
for the iphone 13 and 13 pro i didn't
think this was worth an entire video
because there isn't that much to say but
this is worth a short so here we are so
this is the mid cycle refresh new iphone
color and it's two different greens for
iphone 13 here it's a solid green which
is pretty dark i'd describe it as like a
forest green still glossy still
everything you know and love about the
iphone but a new color to get it back in
the news then for the iphone 13 pro it's
a little more effort this one is called
alpine green and thanks to the matte
finish it's a little bit lighter and the
stainless steel rails are very low
saturation but that's the 13 pros green
and then yeah not a whole lot of other
green stuff in the studio to compare it
to but i'd like to think the color
correction in our videos is so good that
you now know exactly how green these
songs look in your hand for more shorts
like this subscribe to the mkbhd shorts
channel link below
see you over there catch the next one
peace